One-off set bad?
The last time we had a “block” of two or
more consecutive sets on the same plane
was about three years ago, with every set
since being a one-off set. Not only this,
but there hasn’t been a multi-set block in a
brand new plane since Ixalan block concluded
more than eight years ago. These facts stand
in stark contrast to earlier eras of Magic,
which for decades had us venture to one
plane a year over the course of three sets,
often a brand new plane. To be clear, this change
was intentional, its communication was public,
and its reasons for happening were on some level
understandable. Later sets in blocks sold worse
than earlier ones, limited environments were
tricky to make satisfying, and a set with lukewarm
reception getting followed up with an immediate
double and triple-down to the same setting was
certainly not an ideal outcome for developers
or players, you might reasonably say. And yet,
to lay my cards on the table here, I do not like
the new status quo we find ourselves in. Having
every set be a new plane, particularly with five
or more sets per year, makes things feel rushed,
makes it feel like there’s no time to breathe
and to become immersed in a particular world.
And, if I really wanted to let nostalgia take
the wheel on this one, I could tell you that the
gradual pivot from three set blocks to purely
one-off sets has been an unambiguous tragedy,
that we as magic players are fallen and need to
ret-vrn the glory days of 2013, where Magic sets
came in threes and where bold duels could take
place on a middle school lunch table. I’d love
to be able to contribute yet another uncomplicated
piece of ammunition to the siege on the decisions
currently being made by Hasbro, but in truth the
issue of blocks is a bit more complicated than
that. I do think there is something wrong with
what we’re currently doing, where standard-legal
sets take us to 6 or 7 different planes every
single year, but three set blocks don’t really
represent a better vision of the game, just one
with a different set of problems. So here I want
to lay out my case for what has gone wrong, both
past and present, and talk about an alternative
approach to the way we conceptualize set
structuring. And, I’ll be getting into a
very specific missed opportunity that occurred
in 2024 that provides a fascinating case study.
To start with, here’s a very brief timeline of
blocks. The first conventional three-set block
was Mirage block in 1996, and this would set a
trend of three-set blocks beginning in October
that would continue basically uninterrupted
for the following 18 years until the release
of Battle for Zendikar. There were also yearly or
semi-yearly core sets over this span of time, but
aside from that and some extras like masters sets
and un-sets, the general idea was one block a year
and three sets per block. Then, in 2015, Magic:
the Gathering switched to two set blocks, and
this pattern would continue until War of the Spark
in 2019, which was either a standalone set or the
third set of the third Ravnica block, depending
on how you count. From there, sets were a mixture
of one-offs like Kalheim and two set blocks that
returned to a pre-existing plane such as Midnight
Hunt, and the final two-set return-to-block ended
about three years ago with the release of March of
the Machine. Ever since, it’s been all one-offs,
with consecutive sets never featuring the same
setting. And, I guess I’ll start my discussion
of blocks by saying that the current era of
blocks we’re in does not feel very good, and on a
level pretty fundamental to the way we experience
the game. Obviously there are other factors
contributing to the way Magic feels in 2026,
but the set structure being all one-offs isn’t
insignificant. The current progression of things
offers no time to stop and breathe in a particular
plane, no time to be interested about what it has
to offer next, and no spare moments to stop and
reflect. Storylines are bouncing and disconnected,
since we can never stop and watch how a
particular plane changes for any length of time,
only get a fleeting snapshot of it before we’re
off to the next place. Thought and effort is
put into how sets on different planes tie into one
another mechanically for standard purposes, but we
don’t really get to see iterations on a mechanical
theme like we did sometime in the past—everything
a plane has to offer needs to be immediately
present since there’s only one set worth of it.
Three-set block bad?
So as you can tell, I really don’t think what
we’re doing in the present is ideal. However,
that doesn’t mean that the ways sets were
structured in the past were necessarily better,
and to explore that we really
need to talk about 3-set blocks.
This was the way Magic sets were
organized for years and years,
and here I want to hone in on the three blocks I
was fully around for: Return to Ravnica, Theros,
and Khans of Tarkir. RTR was structured into the
namesake set that contained five of the guilds,
Gatecrash which featured the other five, and
Dragon’s Maze which featured all ten guilds.
That final set also focused on “The Maze” which
was a sort of structure built into the city,
and which would host a race in which a “runner”
from each guild would travel to the “Maze’s End”
and this process would ultimately help decide the
balance of power in Ravnica. This is all fine and
cool lore-wise, but it didn’t really get conveyed
that well in the Dragon’s Maze set. The set was
small and thus felt kinda cramped with 10 guilds,
and the things explicitly mentioning parts of the
lore—the gates, the gatekeepers, and Maze’s End
itself—were both few and honestly pretty bad. I
didn’t even know the legendary creatures of
the set were supposed to be Maze-Runners,
because the set didn’t really draw attention to
this element of the story at all. Dragon’s Maze
simply didn’t feel like a proper third set,
rather just a little bit of extra Ravnica
with some attached plot that not enough effort
was put into guiding us through with its design
The following two blocks also each contained a
set that didn’t really fit in, but in the case
of those it was the middle set. Theros the set
established the plane as a setting based around
Greek myths, and also introduced characters
such as Elspeth as a monster-slaying champion
and Xenagos as a satyr planeswalker who aspired
to godhood. Born of the Gods was the second set
of the block, and featured the story of Xenagos
ascending to godhood amidst growing chaos in the
pantheon. Journey into Nyx was the third
set, and focused on the consequences of
Xenagos’s Godhood and the ensuing showdown that
resulted from it. That all sounds fine and good,
but in terms of gameplay, the second
set—Born of the Gods—was very strange,
and a big reason why it stands out as odd is
that the other two sets actually did a really
great job conveying the progression
of the block through their mechanics.
Theros was more focused on the mortal plane
through its heavy usage of heroic and monstrosity
as mechanics, whereas Journey into Nyx was much
more focused around the pantheon of gods and the
conflict within it, which could be seen in its
Constellation mechanic and extra-high density of
enchantments. Born of the Gods, on the other hand,
featured a couple kinda weird mechanics and didn’t
really convey a strong sense of place or time. It
felt more like Theros B-sides than anything else,
just some kinda odd designs to go along with
a group of five gods in order to allow the
fifteen gods to be spread evenly between three
sets. It played an undeniable role in tracing
Xenagos’s storyline, but in most ways other
than that the set was a bit of a disappointment.
The same goes to a lesser extent for the
Tarkir Block—Khans of Tarkir focused on
five warring factions in a world where
Dragons have gone extinct, and Dragons of
Tarkir features an alternate timeline where
Dragons are still around and where Tarkir’s
clans and characters have altered fates. The
middle set, Fate Reforged, was a little odd,
though. Lore-wise it involves Sarkhan traveling
back in time to when Dragons were still around
alongside the five clans, and intervening
in the battle between Ugin and Nicol Bolas.
This is cool as a way to transition between Khans
and Dragons, but in terms of gameplay it just sort
of felt like an awkward mashup of the two sets.
Fate Reforged used three clan keywords from Khans
and two of the changed ones from DTK, it had
some dragons rather than none or a whole bunch,
and the clans were less-three-color
focused than Khans but not quite the
two-color pairings in Dragons. For a middle
set separated from the other two by 1300 years,
this feels more like the middle of an animorphs
cover than it does its own cohesive world. To be
clear, it is still easily the most defensible
third set of the three blocks I’ve mentioned,
and to be honest I can imagine this feeling like
a genuinely compelling three set block with a
handful of changes to the middle set. Nonetheless,
in the form it ended up in, Fate Reforged feels
like a continuation of a trend—one of the sets
in a block being a little awkward, and feeling
more like a stepping stone for story purposes
than a fully thought out landscape of its own.
Two-set block good?
So, these are the two extremes. On the one hand,
you’ve got the current status quo where every set
is a new plane and no setting ever has time
to breathe or experience change, and then you
have the status quo of years past where three set
blocks are the norm and usually feature an awkward
second or third set mostly there for storytelling
purposes. Naturally, I would prefer that we find
our way back to a nice in-between, although
I will say that I don’t think that in-between
would be an endless series of two-set blocks
like we had in the mid-to-late 2010s. One-off
sets can be great as a way to do something funky
and unusual, to explore some bold new aesthetic
territory without committing too hard, and to have
a set where following a story isn’t necessarily a
main priority. Edge of Eternities was a great
one-off set to shake the game up with some out
there aesthetics and new mechanics, and I imagine
Wizards of the Coast is enjoying the opportunity
to gauge community feedback on something like
this. The same goes for Duskmourn—I could have
taken two sets of that, but for the playerbase at
large it makes sense as an interesting experiment
into an unusual setting with a more modern
aesthetic, and a way to introduce a cool new
subtype like rooms that plays into that setting.
Even Outlaws at Thunder Junction would have felt
a lot better if it was surrounded by a couple
two set blocks. It’s okay to have a set that’s
a little silly, a little gimmicky, and a little
odd story-wise—it’s okay to have a hat set.
However, in order for that sort of set to feel
justified, it kind of has to feel differentiated
in some way from what surrounds it, has to have
a degree of adjacency to a non-hat set for the
sake of contrast, right? It might not be clear
exactly what I mean here, so now is a good time
as any to talk about the specific appeals I
find in two set blocks, and why I think they
should once again become a staple part of the
way we structure sets, alongside one-off sets.
The biggest reason I like two-set blocks is that
they’re able to tell the story of a place much
better than a one-set block could. Let’s jump back
to the three set blocks set on brand new planes
I mentioned earlier—Theros and Tarkir. Setting
aside the awkward second set in each of these,
we can notice a pattern here: set one establishes
a setting, and then a later set complicates that
setting, introducing new elements and showcasing
a dramatically changed version of it. This is a
wonderfully blunt form of storytelling, and seeing
that clear change communicated through the design
of the set would be great for getting players to
engage more with the lore and ask more questions,
as opposed to one-off sets that present a snapshot
of things and then dash away at full speed. Two
set blocks with a dramatic change between set
one and set two can also draw out the lifespan
of a given setting without letting things feel
stagnant, and without causing the negative impacts
to limited that have been caused by a lot of
blocks in the past. If both sets of a given block
are full-sized and contain their own important
features and distinguishing characteristics,
you’ll be getting the benefits of being able to
tell a story and letting players stay engaged with
how a particular plane is changing for a longer
span of time, but you’ll also get the benefits of
being able to present each set as something cool
and different, and you can even make each playable
as its own standalone limited format if that’s
a concern. Now, all of this might still seem a
little abstract, so how about we talk about some
specific examples, a few sets since 2023 that
might have been nice as two-set blocks, and which
to me kind of represent missed opportunities.
Murders at Karlov Manor stands out as an
interesting case study, because it’s a set
where they were clearly going for a version
of the establish-then-change framework I
mentioned earlier. Ravnica Remastered came out in
January of 2024, followed by MKM a month later,
and you can kind of see the vision here—remind
people what Ravnica is, then do something cool and
different with the Ravnica setting. I actually
think this framework could have worked here
without that many changes to MKM itself—instead
of Ravnica Remastered one month in advance,
drop an original new Ravnica set two months in
advance. In that set, you’d want to establish
the characters and setting that would be relevant
for the following set, and importantly, you’d want
to feature the guilds! They could maybe be a bit
less present than previous Ravnica sets, but they
definitely need to be there in the first place
and they need to have some sort of tie-in with
the story of Murders at Karlov manor, because why
else are we returning to Ravnica again? There’s no
shortage of places you could set a murder mystery,
and choosing Ravnica, the plane about guilds,
with only a feeble little “oh yeah, this plane
exists” reprints set a month before is just a very
odd choice. So, this is one example of a return-to
set that needed an accompanying set to work well,
and I also think Lorwyn Eclipsed would have
been another great candidate to be a two set
block. It’s an iconic and beloved plane, and the
original Lorwyn super-block was broken into two
separate two-set blocks, one for Lorwyn and one
for its darker counterpart, Shadowmoor. The Lorwyn
Eclipsed set we got was far from bad, but it did
feel a bit rushed as a one-set return to a setting
that was originally built-out with four sets, and
I have to imagine a two set Lorwyn + Shadowmoor
pairing would have made for an appealing choice.
So, there are clear instances where I think we
could have benefitted from a two-set block
when returning to an iconic plane. However,
to me the biggest missed opportunity of the past
three years was actually a new set: Bloomburrow.
I truly cannot think of a more obvious slam dunk
of a two-set block than Bloomburrow. Any competent
market research would have suggested this was
going to be a very popular and well-received set,
and the final product indicates that
Wizards of the Coast was willing to
put in the necessary effort to make it great.
Not only this, but it self-justifies being a
two set block in beautifully simple fashion,
and we can see an indication of this in the
full art lands. Imagine this: the first
set of the block is set in late spring,
and this is where we’re introduced to this
vibrant world and all its creature types. Then,
the second set of the block takes place in autumn,
and there’s decidedly more urgency and darkness as
the various creatures “prepare for winter” in some
sense. What exactly that looks like or how literal
vs metaphorical the preparing for winter element
is could depend on a lot of things, but regardless
it seems like a very natural two-part progression.
Create a setting, and then complicate it. So,
if we were still in an era where two-set blocks
are an accepted part of life, this all lines up
perfectly—a plane that feels cohesive with the MTG
universe, an aesthetic that is almost guaranteed
to be widely appealing, and a setting that very
naturally features change over time that can be
played with in interesting ways. But, we’re
not in that sort of era. We haven’t been in
an era where a new plane could get its own block
for more than eight years. So, it didn’t happen.
Synthesizing the sauce
I vividly remember the excitement of following
the sets in a block when I was in my first few
years of playing the game. These were localized,
tangible stories about what was happening in a
particular place, rather than being just one
puzzle piece in a grand metanarrative about
“The Omenpaths” or something. Anecdotally, when
I talk to people who started playing Magic more
recently and ask what sets they were especially
engaged with as they were getting into the game,
a frequent answer is the four set Phyrexia arc
that concluded in 2023. That observation may or
may not represent a wide swathe of the playerbase,
but it’s not hard to imagine why people might be
excited about something like that: it’s a story
as central to the broader Magic lore as it gets,
told over the span of four sets with time
for anticipation to build as the Phyrexian
threat ramped up. If Bloomburrow had been
a two set block, I have to imagine we would
have seen something similar, possibly to an even
greater extent: large swathes of players fondly
recounting their introduction into the game
being a months-long period where the Magic:
the Gathering found itself centered in a lushly
realized landscape straight out of Redwall.
In a blog post last year, Mark Rosewater laid out
his mindset on blocks in general and Bloomburrow
in specific, and it’s really interesting as
a documentation of how a major decisionmaker
conceptualizes money, people, and how the two
intersect. It starts with the objective metric
that sales are almost always lower for subsequent
sets in a block, and then uses this data point to
make a couple strange extrapolations from there:
that players “don’t want to stay in the same
world for consecutive sets,” and that players
“respond better given a gap between visits” to
a given plane. The issue is, those aren’t things
that sales data can tell you. There are a ton of
reasons why subsequent sets in a block might sell
worse, and imagining that a hypothetical second
Bloomburrow set hypothetically selling worse than
the first would have equated to a players sitting
around being kinda glum about returning
to the plane so soon—well, it’s a very
odd way to conceptualize people and what their
financial decisions mean. And just to reiterate,
I do like one-off sets, and I genuinely understand
the benefits that Wizards of the Coast sees in
them. They allow for greater flexibility, they
allow for a higher density of different settings,
and apparently they sell a bit better too which is
a genuinely understandable consideration. However,
there can be other considerations, because doesn’t
the all one-offs status quo have a cost, too?
I mentioned earlier that I don’t mind having a
hat set here or there—it’s fine to take a fun
little break from longer, more serious story
arcs. But that becomes a harder sell when
every set is a hat set, or at least when every
set receives the same treatment as a hat set.
When every set is a one off—when OTJ is treated
the same as Bloomburrow which is treated the
same as Spiderman which is treated the same as
Lorwyn—it feels a little wrong. It feels like
the people making the game have no faith in the
worlds they’re creating, even when they clearly
have the ability to create something great.
And, at least for me, this disjointed mishmash
of one-off sets makes me less interested in the
game, and the clear lack of creative conviction
that this process exudes makes me less interested
in what Wizards of the Coast has to offer as a
company that, on some level, produces art. I
wish we could see them being a bit more daring,
taking some more risks with what they’re putting
out in pursuit of excellence. You could argue that
releasing a neverending string of funky one-off
sets is a version of being bold and taking risks,
but to me that’s the easier road. The harder
version of being bold is actually committing
to a vision, sincerely believing in and
caring about a product enough to see it
to a satisfying conclusion, and trusting in your
own ability to tell a multiple-part story that
people care about. And I don’t know, in 2026,
I think we could use a little more of that.
Thanks for watching, and wow this video ended up
going a little deeper than I intended. “Why don’t
I make a fun little video about blocks,” I said to
myself in early March. Let me know what you think
of what I’m saying here, this is definitely a
bit outside the realm of what I normally produce.
Anyway, thanks to Archidekt for supporting the
channel. I’ve been exploring some options for
new bracket 4 decks lately, and Archidekt’s
maybeboard categories have been great for
keeping all my thoughts organized. A link to my
decks is down in the description. Also, I’m going
to be at MagicCon Vegas in just a week or so, and
I’ll be running a live podcast episode on Friday
alongside Trinket Mage and a couple friends of
the pod. Come on by if that sounds up your alley!
If you want to support what I do here, you can
grab some high quality sleeves from dragonshield,
affiliate link in description, or you can
support me more directly through Patreon
or a YouTube membership. These folks, some of
whom are onscreen now, help with the rent money,
coffee, and copies of Nexus of Becoming
that help keep this channel chugging along,
and you can join them today! Think about
how accomplished you’ll feel afterward.